now as the groups moved up and down the
boulevard as you heard they're the
largest contingency seem together not
too far from Fremont East and that's
where we find Joe Moller Joe what
exactly is going on there right now
they're fine and Denise yeah people on
edge here right now this protest has
reached here to Las Vegas Boulevard and
Fremont I'll give you a look behind us
here on the protesters a couple hundred
of them have gotten to this point here
at Las Vegas Boulevard and another
almost face to face with the police
officers here a lot of people on edge
lot of people worried about teargas
being being dispersed here a lot of
people have been moving back the police
have been giving warnings for people to
get back on the sidewalk and to move
around so they've been giving a couple
of different warnings here for this
crowd to sort of disperse and the
different directions but this is conduct
to a stop here I've been following this
group since we left the strip around 7
o'clock walked all the way down to this
area here in downtown in the Fremont
East area it's come to a stop here we're
hearing a lot of sirens we're just I
think this group fellas face-to-face
with a lot of people here getting ready
to disperse they're getting these
warnings so we're gonna keep an eye on
this we're kind of keeping our distance
just in case anything does happen there
at that intersection but they are asking
for this crowd to sort of dispersing a
number of directions so we'll keep an
eye on that and we'll give you the
latest and send it back to you